[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
So Chris and I
got to know each
other because we
serve on the board of
GiveDirectly together.
But he's done so many
amazing things in his life.
One of the best parts of
Google.org is that you get
to meet people around the
world who are really digging
in, in the arena, fighting to
make the world a better place .
And Chris has done that in
so many different initiatives
in so many different levels.
Google.org is working
together with him
on the Economic
Security Project.
And Andrew Dunkleman here in
the front row and Florian, also
here-- is Mahmood here.
Our economic opportunity leaders
are charting Google's path
as we support some
of their work.
So if you have questions, also
look for Andrew at the end.
But I thought it would
be helpful to start
with a little bit of
Chris's background,
for those of you
who don't know him.
So you may know that he was
one of the original co-founders
of Facebook.
He was the Head of New Media
for the 2008 Obama campaign
and the former owner
of "The New Republic".
But these days what
propels him most
is his work on rethinking
the social safety net
to give everyone a fair shot.
So I hope everyone was able
to get a copy of their book.
I was telling Chris,
true story, that Andrew
bought this book for me.
And I put it on my
nightstand and I
knew I needed to get to it
and read it before this.
And of course I was
going to do that.
But when I actually opened
it up and started reading it
on the BART, I missed my
BART stop because it is
so well written, so thoughtful.
CHRIS HUGHES: Which is like the
best compliment you can ever
give an author, for the record.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
I mean, I have
a background in econometrics,
and let me tell you,
most of the books I
can put down easily
and I always make my stop.
But this is a phenomenally
well-written, interesting,
personal, thoughtful,
data-driven book, so highly
recommended.
We have copies
here for Googlers.
CHRIS HUGHES: Thank you.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: But
Chris, why don't we start,
because your personal
history, your narrative
does really inform a lot of your
thoughts and a lot of the book.
So maybe just give
us some highlights
from your story,
your personal story.
CHRIS HUGHES: Happily.
So in many ways the
book is a reflection
of my own personal story.
And that leads up to why I
believe a lot of the things
I talk about all the time.
So I grew up in a little town
called Hickory, North Carolina.
It's at the foothills of
the Appalachian Mountains.
And my mom was a
public-school teacher.
She taught high-school math.
And my dad was a
traveling paper salesman,
sort of the middleman
between the big companies
that manufactured the paper
and small-town printers.
And we had a just
typical sort of
small-town, middle-class life.
I went to public schools.
And I was an only child.
My parents were a
little bit older.
It was very bucolic.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Wasn't
it literally like the town
that Mayberry was built on?
CHRIS HUGHES: My dad was
born in Mount Airy, which is
the setting for Mayberry, yes.
And he grew up as the son of
the groundskeeper for a golf
course.
So that was his trajectory.
So I ended up applying
to a boarding school.
I googled best high school--
well, actually at the time
it was Yahoo search.
This was like the late '90s.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: A long time
ago folks, a long time ago.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yes.
I looked up the best high school
in America, ended up applying.
I got financial aid to
go to a boarding school.
And then from there,
got into Harvard,
got financial aid,
a scholarship,
to go there And got to
know Mark Zuckerberg
a little bit our freshman year
and then ended up roommates
with him sophomore year.
We started Facebook
and the Facebook story
is somewhat well known.
And the rocket ship took off.
So my life, though, changed
dramatically in the years
after Facebook.
I worked for three years
there doing communications,
marketing, and product.
But I wrote the book because
for three years worth of work,
I got a boatload of money.
When Facebook went public,
it was nearly half a
billion dollars.
And that is nothing
but a lucky break.
I mean, there's nothing else--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Your take of
it was half a billion dollars--
CHRIS HUGHES: Yes.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
--just to be clear, yeah.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yes,
Facebook's [INAUDIBLE]..
But it was a lucky break.
And so I wrote the book
because initially I thought
that my case was really unique.
And I have come to believe
that my case is, in many ways,
extreme, but it's
actually not that unique,
that a small group of people
are consistently getting lucky
while everybody else has a
hard time making ends meet.
It's not to say a hundred people
are working hard but only 1%
is doing really well.
And that is a specific
decision that we
have made in our economy
to structure it that way.
And we do really have
the power to change it.
So that's where
the book came from.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: I thought
that your whole view on luck
was very interesting.
So I thought I'd read just
a little bit from the book
when you talk about this.
You say that, "Saying
people get lucky
is not a denial that they
work hard and deserve
positive outcomes.
It is a way of
acknowledging that
in a winner-take-all economy,
small chance encounters like
who you sit next to it at dinner
or who your college roommate is
have a more significant impact
than they have ever had before.
And in some cases the collection
of these small differences
can add up to create
immense fortunes."
You know, I worked at
the Gates Foundation
before coming to Google,
and Bill Gates also--
I was always struck by how
he said when people said,
what's the reason
for your success,
and he would say number
one would be luck, that I
lived in a privileged family.
I was able to go to a school
where I had access to computers
in a time that was--
so recognizing
hard work, but also
recognizing the place of luck.
And it seems like,
for a lot of folks,
we don't want to have
that conversation.
CHRIS HUGHES: I
think that's right.
I think that we
often divvy it up.
We say some people over
here, they get lucky.
Like that guy Chris who
roomed with Mark Zuckerberg,
he's one of the lucky ones.
Over here we've got the
people who work hard.
Mark Zuckerberg, he
worked very hard.
And never the twain shall meet.
I think in reality almost
always the two people
are both working hard--
when we look at success,
are both working hard
and are fortunate.
I think Fortune 500 CEOs,
as I say in the book,
are some of the hardest-working
people out there,
but they are benefiting from
an economy that provides
some disproportionate rewards.
The janitors who work in those
buildings or in a building
like this are also
working very, very hard,
but the way that we've
structured our economy
means that--
quite literally we know
from the economic data--
they haven't gotten a meaningful
wage boost in decades,
in nearly 40 years.
So one of the reasons that
I wanted to write the book
was to try to dispel
this notion of luck
being something that is
just one or two people,
but instead there's
a kind of fortune
that the economy is providing
to a small number of people
while everybody else is having
a hard time making ends meet.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Well, why don't we
go right into your policy
prescription for this?
So you have an idea about
expanding the Earned Income Tax
Credit so that every
working American who
lives in a household earning
less than $50,000 a year
could receive a guaranteed
income of at least $500
a month.
So we're at this moment.
Economy's humming along.
Unemployment's at
an all-time low.
This would be creating
a whole new entitlement
at a time when we're talking
about entitlement reform.
So why this and why now?
CHRIS HUGHES: Well,
the numbers, I think,
don't tell the whole story.
The stock market
is at record highs.
Unemployment is
near record lows.
But economic opportunity is
also at a near record low.
So what do I mean by that?
I mean a sense that the people
who do well for themselves
will be able to pay their
bills and their kids
might do a little
bit better than they.
The median wages
have not meaningfully
budged in 40 years, and the
cost of living is up by 30%.
And it's not just
in the Bay Area
or in New York where we
have all of these insane
challenges with housing
and transportation
and health care, child care.
It's across the board,
across the country.
Wages are flat.
Life is more expensive.
People feel like they
can't make ends meet.
And Donald Trump was obviously
elected for a whole host
of complex, interwoven reasons.
But I think one of the
things his election has done
is been a wake-up
call, that people
on the left and the right
feel like the economy is not
working for them
and that we have
to do something differently.
So in my view, sometimes
the best solution
is the simplest, cash.
Cold hard money put
in the hands of people
who need it provides more
economic opportunity,
we know from the
evidence, and is
remarkably efficient in
offering that opportunity.
And it can be the kind
of thing that we do.
So we can talk a little bit
about the Earned Income Tax
Credit and the frameworks,
but at the end of the day what
I'm interested in is embracing
the dignity and the freedom
that I think everybody should
have to be able to figure out
what they want to
do with their time,
what they want to invest in.
And cash is unlike any other
intervention in that it doesn't
say, you go here at this time.
You've got to go to
that government office
to fill out these programs.
We'll give you
these SNAP benefits,
but don't buy any fish
with it or all these kind
of crazy restrictions.
Instead, cash says you are the
master of your own destiny.
And I think it's a fundamentally
respectful way of empowering
people that we also happen
to know works very well.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Well, let's
dive into that a little bit.
We bonded on
GiveDirectly's board.
So Google.org has invested
in GiveDirectly as well.
We're big believers in
direct cash assistance,
especially in
developing countries.
What's the evidence
base that in a place
like the United States
that this kind of aid
is going to be the
most effective?
CHRIS HUGHES: So I came
to this whole issue
actually from the
perspective of philanthropy,
through the GiveDirectly lens.
And specifically
after Facebook's IPO,
my husband and I
made a commitment
to give away the vast majority
of our wealth in our lifetime.
And so we faced
this big challenge.
But one of the biggest
first motivating questions
is, how do we get the
most bang for the buck?
Yes, it's a lot of money--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: If
you're going to give it away,
you want to give it away well.
CHRIS HUGHES: --however, if
you're going to give it away,
you want to give it away well.
And in some sense it was
overwhelming without that kind
of heuristic.
I'm sure some people in this
audience or on the livestream
have experienced
something similar where
there is no shortage of causes.
I mean, we could go through
a whole list of things
that we care about.
But one way of narrowing
it down is like, OK,
well if we care about poverty
and economic opportunity,
what's the most
efficient way to help?
And I went through the
international door,
initially through GiveDirectly.
And I have a whole chapter
in the book about a journey
that I took to check out
several different programs.
And I really came to believe
that cash, dollar for dollar,
is more effective
internationally.
There are well over
200 studies that have
looked at the power of cash.
There's a great
synthesis of all of them
in an Overseas
Development Institute
report that got put out last
year, which is fantastic,
shows that health educations
improve, education improves.
Not to say we still don't
need hospitals and schools.
However, on balance,
I think we should
be asking if we're
going to invest you know
a dollar in a hospital,
might it be better
to provide that dollar
in cash for people
to be able to go and
find the health resources
that they need?
So I came in through
the international door,
became convinced
by the evidence,
and then took a
step back and said,
well, this works in Kenya.
Why can't it work here?
And in the US, there is less
evidence but still significant
amounts.
We have a small guaranteed
income in Alaska.
The Eastern Band of
Cherokee have one.
And then majorly there's the
Earned Income Tax Credit.
We have the largest
cash-transfer program
in the world.
And we know quite a lot
about what happens when
you provide people with money.
So I really came to see it
as the most effective way
to provide economic
opportunity, in a time when
a lot of other people, mind you,
are coming to the issue of UBI
more from the frame of
artificial intelligence
and automation and
self-driving cars and rise
of the robots, which is
a different door off--
it can take you to a very
similar kind of solution,
but it's a different way in.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Yeah.
So what's unique
about your proposal
as well is that whereas
a lot of UBI advocates
are just saying everyone
gets this amount regardless,
you believe in having
a work element to this.
So why don't you
just speak to that.
Why do you think
work's important?
Why would you weave that in?
CHRIS HUGHES: So
a lot of this is
grounded in the context
in which I grew up.
In the world I grew up, everyone
was working in some way,
and people wanted to work.
Now it was often in
the formal economy.
It was sometimes not.
So I believe that
people in America--
the people at least
that I've met,
and the empirical evidence
I think also shows this--
want to be of purpose to
themselves, their families,
or their communities.
This is just like a
fundamental belief of mine,
that there is a myth out there
that people just want to--
I mean, particularly the
welfare queen, right?
This is the Reagan idea
that all these people,
they just want to
live on the dole.
If people have enough money,
they're just going to hang out.
And I don't see that.
And I think psychological
evidence shows that people
want to be of purpose.
They want to be in touch
with their communities.
I think there's an
immense evidence
base that shows that people
want to be of purpose.
So my view is if you are
working, whether it's
in a traditional job or
an untraditional one,
you shouldn't live in poverty.
Sounds so obvious, right,
I know, but it's not true.
It's not true in America today.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: By
untraditional you also
include caregiving, which
I think disproportionately
impacts women around the world.
And in the US as well
women do the largest share
of childcare, but then
also elder care as well.
And a lot of times that sets
back their economic situation.
And so I think one of
the interesting things
about your proposal is that you
would equally value caregiving.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yeah.
I think specifically we should
say if you're at home taking
care of young kids, we
should recognize what you're
doing is the work that it is.
If you have a dependent
over 70 who you're primarily
responsible for--
I mean, we have so
much evidence to show,
as baby boomers grow
older, people are literally
dropping out of the workforce
to be able to stay at home,
because it's cheaper
for them to do
that than stay in the workforce
and pay for nursing-home fees.
So that is a kind of
work which, right now,
our government
does not recognize.
You've got to go to Burger
King and get a minimum-wage job
and then you're working.
But if you're taking care of
your aging parent at home,
that doesn't count.
I think that's wrong headed.
I also think education is work.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Yeah, being a student.
CHRIS HUGHES: So
being a student is--
I was on financial aid.
It's always hard to do
the counterfactuals,
but I didn't drop out
of school to go work
on Facebook full time.
I didn't even really
have that as an option.
It wasn't like I was going
to move out to Palo Alto
and work at Starbucks during
the day and then at night--
I mean, people do,
but that was not--
I was going to--
I liked college.
I liked the opportunities.
So I decided to stay in school.
But I think a lot
of college students
today already have
a guaranteed income.
It's just--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Mom and dad.
CHRIS HUGHES: --provided
by mom and dad, exactly.
And there are a lot
of people who don't.
And so that is how structural
classism and the racism
that overlaps with
that I think do
get passed down
generation by generation
when some people
don't have to work.
They can just focus on their
grades and get good grades,
get a good job, et cetera.
So I think we should take,
to get to your question,
I think we should take a very
broad definition of work,
not the kind of cynical
work requirements
that end up cropping up in a
lot of political discussions
but instead say, if
you're doing something
for your family or
your community--
which I think is
effectively everyone--
then you shouldn't
live in poverty.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: You
touched on just a minute ago
how a lot of folks, especially
from sort of Silicon Valley,
are coming UBI through
the lens of fear
around evolving nature
of work, automation, rise
of the robots, whatnot.
But that's not your perspective.
That's not the doorway
through which you walk
to get to a guaranteed income.
CHRIS HUGHES: It
makes sense to me
why people are
extremely concerned
about artificial
intelligence and the changing
nature of work.
I'm just focused on
the here and now today.
And we already know that
automation and globalization
have torn jobs apart in America.
In the past decade according
to Princeton economists,
94% of the jobs that
have been created
have been part time,
contract, or temporary.
So in other words they've
been fundamentally unstable.
So yes, there is work, and
yes unemployment is low.
However, if people don't have
fundamental economic stability
in their lives, they
live on the brink.
And we know a lot from
psychological evidence
about the stress that that
introduces, which we can talk
more about if it's of interest.
So I'm very much inspired
by the idea of a UBI
that provides everybody--
I mean, not just people who
are making $50,000 or less
but everybody the kind
of financial security
that they deserve.
I mean particularly
in a world where
there's mass technical
unemployment, that, I think,
is something very
serious to think through.
I just don't want us to
hang out and wait for 2040.
I think we need to
make a down payment.
We can and should make
a down payment today
in modernizing the
Earned Income Tax Credit,
making it monthly, creating
a kind of guaranteed income
for a lot of people.
And then if and when jobs
are wiped out wholesale,
then we have a
framework in place.
And it's much easier, just
like with Social Security,
it started small and then
got expanded over time.
Similar idea, let's start in a
more modest way than a true UBI
and build over time as
the challenges arise.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: I
want to just pick up
on something you just mentioned,
which was the immense stress
and strain that
comes from living
from paycheck to paycheck and
at the margins financially.
If you don't mind, I'll
just read some of the data
that you put in your book.
So there is an experiment
done where there were
poor and well-off participants.
And they scored equally
well on an intelligence test
beforehand.
And then they were
asked what they
would do if they had
to deal with $300
of unexpected expenses, and
then given an intelligence test.
And it stayed about the same.
Then they changed and
said, OK, well how
about if you had $3,000
in unexpected expenses?
And the IQ for the
well-off participants
didn't drop in the next test,
but for the poor participants
it dropped 15%, just because
if you think about their brain
having been primed and
immediately just needing
to deal with that
stress and that anxiety
and thinking about it even
in just a theoretical way
and how much that
affected their decisions.
I was telling Chris
beforehand, there's
a book that's been making
its rounds around Google.org
and the Grow with Google teams
called "White Working Class"
by Joan Williams, which is
a great complement, I think,
to this book because
just taking us
through some of the realities
of class and structure.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yeah,
and while we're
in the business of recommending
other books, the other book
that is on this topic too that--
well, this one, but
I was going to say
it's another book called
"Scarcity" by Sendhil
Mullainathan and Eldar Shafir
who have written-- it's
an incredibly
well-documented book.
I chose this one study to cite
in my book from their book,
but it's full of stuff--
I mean, they go through--
specifically it studies
the effect of scarcity
on the brain in
decision-making power.
They make some
positive arguments.
When we have scarce time,
it can be good for us.
If you only have 10
minutes left in a meeting,
everybody all of a sudden
zeros in if there's still
stuff to get done and
puts everything aside.
But it's often very
destructive to the brain too.
And they look at the
study that I cite,
which is in a New Jersey mall,
but they go to the developing
world too and what
it's like in the period
before harvest for people
who are living hand
to mouth and then
the period after.
So consistently what I think,
taking a step back, what we see
is that poverty actually has
a physical effect on the body
and a very real effect
on the brain as well.
There are some folks out there
who are studying, specifically
for children who are
raised in poverty,
there is some reason to believe
that the brains are actually
wired differently
than for families
who are not in poverty.
So we tend to think, well, poor
people, why can't they just--
when I say we, many people
tend to think poor people,
why can't they
just figure it out?
Why can't they just--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Why
don't they just go to school?
CHRIS HUGHES: Why don't
just go to school?
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Why don't they
just invest in their future?
CHRIS HUGHES: I did it, so
they should be able to do that.
And there are
fundamental, I think,
questions about, OK,
with what resources?
To go back to school
let's say, you've
got to be able to pay
$1,000 for the tuition
at a community college.
You've got to be able to make up
for the lost hours for the job
that you don't have.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
You have to get there.
CHRIS HUGHES: You've got
to be able to get there
with gas money and you've
got to figure out childcare.
Which by the way, the
costs are skyrocketing.
And so it's like
well, clearly people
should just be in education.
That's not to mention
that when you show up
for class at 7:00 PM, which
is connecting to the point,
psychologically there's
every evidence to believe,
because you have been juggling
8 million things all day,
you actually may be--
you know, we all
know our moments
and our days when our mental
bandwidth is less and so much
of it's already been used up.
So it's so easy to say,
well, people should just
be able to take advantage
of opportunities.
But I think we have to have
a little bit more of a--
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
So your argument is--
CHRIS HUGHES: --nuts and bolts
conversation about how it work.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: --giving
folks at least enough
of a floor to stand on--
CHRIS HUGHES: Exactly.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
--to help them.
So stepping back a bit, and
I'm going to ask just a few
more questions and then
we're going to open up
the mic for live question.
And I think we have some
on the Dory as well,
but the Dory is not working yet.
But we'll get there.
All right, so
stepping back a bit,
so last year was defined
by a growing "techlash".
So as a tech founder
yourself and someone
who thinks a lot about
inequality, what do you think
is the role of tech
companies like Google?
CHRIS HUGHES: Top line I
think that the skepticism
about the role of companies
like Google or Facebook
is going to be healthy
in the long term.
I think it's overdue.
We've talked a lot
about the opportunities
that companies like this
one and Facebook provide,
which has been important
and constructive.
We have not talked enough
about the responsibilities
that companies like
Google and Facebook have.
And I think that there
are responsibilities
that it's possible to talk
about at the company level,
and then there are
responsibilities
that it's possible to talk about
at the level of individuals
and leadership.
So Facebook in particular is
going through in the first set,
on the company side, although
Google too, to some extent,
on making sure people hear
people that they disagree with.
Don't just log on and have
the filter bubble problem.
Certainly make sure
that there's room
for healthy debate of
political kinds of issues,
that it's not just about
entertainment and ads.
And definitely make
sure that foreign powers
can't hack our elections.
Wherever you fall and
however you interpret
what happened in 2016,
everybody I think
should agree that there is
an immense responsibility
on the part of companies to
make sure that nothing like that
happens again, and on
the part of government.
Which to be honest, in some ways
I worry more about government
because I'm not, unfortunately,
convinced our elections
are as secure as we think.
But the companies, I think,
are owning that responsibility.
Then on that level
of individuals--
and just speaking
on economic issues--
that's where I think we
all have a responsibility
to talk about the way
the economy is working
and the opportunities
that people
like the ones in this room have
and what that does or doesn't
mean for the people
who make your lives,
our lives all possible.
So it's fun to talk
about a UBI in 2040,
and I want to do that more.
But let's not forget that--
and not just on the
guaranteed income--
guaranteed income, health care
for all, higher minimum wage.
Let's just not forget
that these things matter
immensely in the here and now.
And with that comes
the responsibility
for all of us to figure out.
We all have different
ways of engaging,
but I think we all
need to be more.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
All right, I'm
going to ask one last question.
Then we'll open it up,
if folks want to start
moving towards the mic.
So switching topics, I think
one of my favorite parts
about the book was your
incredibly humble and honest
discussion about your experience
at "The New Republic".
I know you were hoping I
was going to bring that up.
CHRIS HUGHES: I'd love to.
I think it's important to talk
about failures and successes
alike.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
If you could just,
for folks who don't
know the summary,
maybe just tell a little
bit about that experience,
and then also how it's tied to
this very pragmatic approach
that you just talked about,
the here and now, taking
positive steps forward.
CHRIS HUGHES: So after Facebook
I went and worked for President
Obama for a couple years
on the '08 campaign.
Then in 2012 I ended
up buying a magazine
called "The New Republic",
for multiple reasons.
The most important one
was I really believe
in the power of journalism
to not just hold
the people in power accountable
but to create a more civilized
educated discourse
in our country,
and specifically the
kinds of journalism
that "The New Republic"
had historically done.
Those of you who might not
know "The New Republic"--
some of you might-- but it's
sort of in the category of "New
Yorker" or "Economist", these
kinds of magazines that--
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Long-thought pieces.
CHRIS HUGHES: Long-m form
journalism, thoughtful pieces.
"New Republic" always had a
little bit more of an edge,
but it was a kind of journalism
that I wanted and continue
to want to try to support,
and I think particularly
in a time of
transition, needed it.
I did come in guns
blazing though.
So after Facebook and Obama--
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
I think a lot of us
have that tendency maybe.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yeah, probably
in rooms like this one.
I wanted to figure
out not just how
to bring the journalism to new
audiences of millions, tens
of millions, but also how to
find a sustainable business
model right for long-form,
highbrow kind of journalism.
So we hired a lot of people.
I invested a lot of money,
millions of dollars.
We got bigger offices, and we
just did all of these things.
Whatever you think we were
doing with the big ambitions,
we were probably doing.
And then over the
course of several years,
we weren't getting any traction.
We weren't selling ads.
I talk a little bit
in the book about what
we were trying to do.
The subscription numbers,
they bounced up a little bit.
But we were hitting
a wall in many ways.
And my own desire to broaden the
audience of "The New Republic",
I had a hard time
communicating how
we were going to do that and
hold onto the values that
made it special.
So anyway, what
ended up happening is
I learned the hard way that
"The New Republic" had always
been a small print magazine with
a circulation of about 35,000.
It had never turned a profit.
I think once in the '80s it
did and they bought pizza
and then it wasn't
a profit anymore.
So it had always effectively
been a nonprofit dressed up
as a company.
And you know, it
was OK that it was
for a small, select audience.
It wasn't going to reach
tens of millions of people
and be the next
"New York Times".
So I learned that, in
some ways the hard way.
And I talk a little
bit about in the book,
I wish that we had made
much more modest investments
and really starting from
a very different place.
So the reason all of this is
relevant to the work I do now
is because I think before
"The New Republic" experience
I would have been of the
type to say, UBI or bust.
You know, it's got to
be go big, go home.
You've got to like really--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: We call
those moonshots around here.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yeah.
And clearly I'm still very
much inspired by that idea.
Those values are the reason
why I work on what I work on.
However, I have no issues in
having a more modest approach,
because I think that embracing
$500 a month for everybody
who makes $50,000 or less is
not necessarily the end goal.
It is an important
place to start.
There's been a couple
articles that say, oh, this
is too modest.
Here I'm a follower rather
than a leader on the issue.
And if creating a space to
try something modest is--
in my view, that's
exactly where I
want to be is building
that bridge, if you will,
to the future
rather than letting
the ideal make the
short-term gains impossible.
So that's how it's relevant
to work I'm doing now.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: All right,
let's take our questions.
Do you want to share your
name with your question?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
My name's Max.
Thanks for coming.
So it seems like
your plan really
focuses on the national
version of the EITC.
A lot of states, including
California, have EITCs as well.
And we expanded ours recently.
Few people know actually that
San Francisco and New York
also--
New York City-- also
have very small EITCs.
San Francisco's has
been cut in the past.
And I think there's
an opportunity.
We have a mayor election and a
general election in November.
I'm curious if you think
there's opportunity
to advance those kind of
problems on a more local level
as well.
CHRIS HUGHES: Absolutely.
It's a short answer.
I do talk a lot about a
national policy in the book.
And it's only been six months
since I finished the book.
But I would, if I can rewrite
the book in real time,
I would spend more time with
the kinds of near-term things
that can be done,
because I definitely
don't want people
to think we've got
to just go national or go home.
So there are EITCs,
earned income tax credits,
in the states.
And by the way, even though
it's called a tax credit,
the way that's experienced
is people just get cash.
Tens of millions of Americans
just get a check in the mail.
And it's because
it's refundable,
which means that it's lived as
a kind of annual influx of cash.
So in the book I make
the case for making
it monthly, the bigger
definition of work,
and also making
it flat so people
know what they're getting.
Right now it's
very hard to know.
You can get different
amounts where
you live, the size
of your family,
how much money you
made, et cetera.
So there's a lot to be
done in the short term.
So cities absolutely
can lead the way--
San Francisco, New York,
Mayor Michael Tubbs,
who is in Stockton, California.
If you guys don't know
this guy, go google him,
because he's the youngest mayor
of a major city in the United
States.
And he's 27 now.
He is a phenomenal leader.
He is running a
demonstration with the group
that I co-run, Economic
Security Project,
to provide a guaranteed
income to people there.
We invite more people to talk
about what's going on there,
love to go to Stockton together.
There's so much work.
So really if people
are interested in that,
I'd love to talk more.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS HUGHES: Y Combinator
is doing a study.
So there's a lot
on the city level,
and there's a lot
of state level too.
EITCs do exist at a state level.
I think the key is not
just making them bigger--
sure, that's important--
but really modernizing them.
So the key challenge I think
in the gig economy of today
is the fundamental
instability of income.
And so providing it monthly,
even if it's only a couple
hundred dollars, can,
in my conversations,
really provide
important stability.
So there's work to be
done at a state level,
and then in the long term
at the federal level too.
But there's no shortage of
places to roll up our sleeves
and get going.
Thanks.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: All right,
from the Dory, So in your book
you recognize that
philanthropy alone can't
support a guaranteed income.
Quote, "All of the money that
billionaires have committed
through the Giving
Pledge would only
fund a guaranteed income
for a single year."
So what's the most helpful
role that philanthropy
can play to advance this idea?
CHRIS HUGHES: Philanthropy
can do so much.
So it's important
to say, it's not
like we can fund the guaranteed
income through philanthropy.
So I make that
point in the book.
But there is a real need
for more philanthropy
in this space.
A lot of people talk about UBI.
And I've been working on
this for several years now,
and there's a lot of talk
and a lot of interest.
There's not as much
money as you would think.
Fortunately Google.org
is helping us,
not necessarily, I
think, through UBI
but thinking through
the way the EITC
can adapt to the
future of work today.
But I think that we
need a lot more people
to invest in this space.
So for instance, we have
a match out for Stockton
where we funded the beginnings
of the guaranteed income pilot
there.
There is a lot more funding
there that is required.
We need research.
You know, I'm not an economist.
I do love economics, but we
need think tanks thinking
through how to do this.
We need to talk about,
there are other ways
to attack this problem.
You could put a tax on carbon
and distribute the revenue
as a dividend.
You could think about a
financial transaction tax.
You could think
about all kinds--
So there's so much
need for philanthropy
to catalyze and develop
the conversation.
And part of what
I do every day is
to talk with people who
are interested about this,
to move it.
It's just not the way that we
can fund it in the long term.
Literally if you took all
the money from the Giving
Pledge combined, it would fund
a guaranteed income for a year,
and then be gone.
So powerful--
however, public policy
has to be the
long-term solution.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Focus
on the catalytic work.
Let the government--
CHRIS HUGHES:
There's no other way
the numbers add up without it.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Great.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for your talk.
You defended the
work requirement
a little bit ago
early on in the talk
by saying that
people want to work.
If they want to work, why
have a work requirement?
CHRIS HUGHES: I think,
well, a couple of things.
So the way work requirements
as a phrase is used
is usually somewhat
cynically to try
to throw people off of rolls.
I'm much more interested in
expanding the definition.
I have found in my own work,
in my own work and economics
community project, people don't
understand the idea of cash
unless it's in some kind
of symbiotic context.
So by that I mean--
I'll take my parents
as a good example.
Like my dad, particularly
in the early days,
he's like, I don't get it.
You just get cash?
Why do I get it?
Where does it come from?
Is it going to keep
coming or does it run out?
And am I going to have
to pay for it eventually?
And my dad's a pretty smart
guy, and it just conceptually
didn't make sense.
Similarly, I've been
in North Carolina,
in Mississippi, and in
California and Alaska,
all across the country.
And people really
struggle to understand
the idea of just manna
from heaven, cash
that comes from the clouds.
However, if you say
you are struggling
to make ends meet in
some way and you deserve
to have economic
opportunity and cash
can provide that, you go from
having a group where it's
furrowed eyebrows,
confusion, I don't get it,
I don't support it, to
people being like, yeah,
that is fundamentally what
the American dream is about.
So in my view, the
conversation about work
is really a way to recognize
what everyone is already doing
and a way to invite people into
understanding why we should not
have poverty in
the United States
or why we should provide
economic opportunity
through cash.
And in my own experience, it
has moved the needle so much
and made the whole idea of
cash much more understandable
and approachable.
And so I think it's really
an asset for those of us
who believe in the power of
cash to use in the long term.
AUDIENCE: So politics.
Thank you.
CHRIS HUGHES: Say it again?
AUDIENCE: I said, so politics.
CHRIS HUGHES: No.
No, wait, come back, because
that's not what I'm saying.
AUDIENCE: Well I mean--
CHRIS HUGHES: No,
no, conceptually--
AUDIENCE: --as opposed to a
negative income tax, which
I think is as easy
to explain but you
have a harder time defending.
And when you get into
the work requirement
you have to deal
with, what is work
and how do you get all of
those untraditional jobs
like caregiving
to be recognized?
And if you skip over that, you
don't have to deal with that.
So you're taking on
a logistic, and I
guess you're arguing that it
has some explanatory power
to do that.
CHRIS HUGHES: No,
well two things.
I think there's
conceptual clarity.
I mean, politics is
one route, and that
is sort of what's sitting--
that's not actually so much
what I'm interested in.
I would challenge
you to ask people--
I was in a public housing
outside of Jackson, Mississippi
two weeks ago.
And ask people what they
think of a UBI or cash.
It's such a foreign concept.
Whereas if you talk
about a monthly
earned income tax credit--
many of them were single moms--
that recognizes what they were
doing--
I'm not there to sell
the idea to them.
I was there to be in
conversation to figure out
if it could be useful.
It makes a conceptual clarity
that opens the opportunity
to have the dialogue with
people in the first place,
not market it as a
kind of political idea.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS HUGHES: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm David Bourne.
I work in consumer
hardware sustainability
with my colleague Anna.
So I've, I think,
personally come
to largely the same conclusion
you have about the way
to proceed on this issue.
But I wanted to ask
you about, is there
room to evaluate
the role of what
it means to be an employer?
What is truly a contract?
What should be an employee?
What's core versus context?
Even at Google I think we all
sit next to a bunch of TVCs
and we wonder, oh, I thought
they were an employee.
So is there room to
redefine the role of what
it means to be an
employer and avoid some
of the instability you talked
about with the contracting gig
economy?
CHRIS HUGHES: I think so.
There's an important
conversation
to be had about what's
the relationship
between an employer
and employee.
When is contracting
really contracting?
When does it not smell--
not smell exactly-- right,
like when is the relationship
actually really different?
I'm very interested in the
expanded definition of work,
though, that brings in so many
of these people who aren't even
in contracting relationships.
So for me it's like
if you're on payroll
or if you're part
of the gig economy
or if you're doing some kind
of work that isn't recognized,
then that shouldn't
be all recognized
as a kind of work of sorts.
It's the way we talk about it.
So in terms of the opportunity
to redefine that relationship,
I think that's an important
thing that we need to do too,
but it's a little bit
out of area of expertise.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: We'll
do a quick one from the Dory
and then we'll get yours.
So here's a question
about the phaseout.
So your program
would give $6,000
a year to people earning
a little bit less
than $50,000 and $0 to
people earning $50,001.
First of all, is that right?
And then are you concerned
about work disincentives
arising from this cliff?
CHRIS HUGHES: No.
With all of these things we
have to have some kind of cliff.
So cliff is the
policy term so that
when you don't have this
weird perversion of employers
paying $50,001 or $49,000.
So we worked with the Institute
for Taxation and Economic
Policy to think through
all of these numbers.
And one of the key things is
figuring out exactly where
does that cliff begin?
Does it begin at $48,000?
Does it begin at $47,000?
Does it begin further on down
and how far down does it go?
So the numbers that I had for
the book are, in many ways,
a first kind of
provocative attempt
to get the conversation started.
And then one of the things
that, thanks to the support
of Google.org, that Economic
Security Project is doing
is literally answering this
exact kind of question.
How steep should the cliff be?
Had this idea of
moving $50,000 around
so it's different in
California versus Mississippi,
for instance.
How would you factor
in cost of living?
There are a lot of even more
granular technical kinds
of questions.
But my hope with the book
was to invite more people
into the conversation
so we can have
more minds thinking about it.
But I do think $50,000
is not, by any means,
an arbitrary kind of number.
It's very much where
I think we can afford
and I think it captures
a lot of people
who are in the lower-middle
class right now
who technically aren't in
poverty under the statistics
but who often can dip into
it and then dip out of it.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: And you
can fix the marriage penalty
that way too.
CHRIS HUGHES: Well
the marriage penalty
is a big question, right?
One of the things that I
really believe in strongly
and one of the virtues of
a UBI and the conversation
is that every adult gets it.
And we add all these UBI
experiments in the '70s,
and there was a sense
that in one of them,
in the Seattle experiments,
that divorce rates went up.
And at the time it made
people skeptical of it.
But now from our
vantage point a lot
of people, particularly
women, say well no,
that's indicative of a
sense that people could
exit relationships they
really didn't want to be in,
because they knew that
on the other side of it
they would have some
financial security.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Yeah, some stability.
CHRIS HUGHES: So I do
think that this should
be on a per capita basis,
on a per-person basis
to really embrace the
individual freedom for people
to be able to deal with.
We have all kinds of marriage
penalties and allowances
in the tax code now.
And this would, when and
if we get to a moment
when this is being actually
implemented at a federal level,
then I think we have
to think about how it's
going to interact with those.
But the fundamental
value that I do
think is important to hold on
to is that everybody gets it.
It's recognizable.
It's the same amount.
And you have it
even if you decide
you want to leave a
relationship that isn't working.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Krishna.
Sorry, I haven't
read the book yet.
You probably have
the answer there.
What is the international
comparison for this?
Is there any developed countries
that have something like UBI,
and how are they raising
money in terms of taxation,
and how are they
distributing the money, is
the right initial comparison.
CHRIS HUGHES: So there are a lot
of countries thinking about it,
but no country that really
has a long-term guaranteed
income for now.
But we're in a moment.
This idea is old.
It's been around
hundreds of years.
But it tends to come in these
patterns where lots of people
pay attention to it and then it
fades and then it comes back.
We're in one of these.
We're on the upswing.
Finland has a big experiment.
Ontario up in Canada has
an enormous $100 million,
the biggest one.
GiveDirectly is running
a pilot in Kenya.
The idea is being explored
in a really serious way.
But it's still on the
forefront of where we are.
So the short answer
to your question
is no, no country right now.
Iran has a small one that was
established, but inflation
has taken it so far
that it's minimized it
so significantly that
it doesn't really--
AUDIENCE: How about Alaska
with their oil checks
or something, dividends?
CHRIS HUGHES: Yeah, up in
Alaska we have something close.
There's a guaranteed check.
It's not so much a
guaranteed income.
Every year every Alaskan
gets $1,500, which is huge.
If you have a family of
four, every Alaskan--
if you have a family
of four, you're
getting a check in October
of $6,000 every year.
So if you think
about median incomes,
that's a boost of about 10%.
So imagine whatever you make,
getting an extra check of 10%.
It's meaningful.
And we know some about
what people do with it.
We certainly know
that people love it.
They don't have an income
tax or a sales tax up there.
Alaskans would rather pay a
sales tax by a factor of two
to one than see their
Permanent Fund dividend--
that's what it's called--
disappear.
So it's very powerful.
It was started by a Republican
governor 40 years ago.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
It's funded out of oil.
CHRIS HUGHES: It's funded
out of oil royalties.
It's a fantastic
reference point.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: And no
one thinks of it as welfare.
They just think about
it as their entitlement
because they are Alaskans.
CHRIS HUGHES: Yeah, it's
a common inheritance.
They do.
Yeah, that's right.
It's something that everyone
gets and everyone is due.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Maybe
we'll take our last question,
and then Chris might have a few
minutes afterwards for folks.
CHRIS HUGHES: Sure, happily.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Garrett.
Thanks for speaking today.
The question I had was for
someone that's been successful
with Facebook, a lot
of folks might say,
great, this person must know
what they're talking about.
Let's listen to them and
let's hear what sort of policy
recommendations they have--
and your experience with
the Obama administration.
The question I have is
how, as a white male
would you, in the United
States, fold in or at least
overcome some of
that blindnesses
that you would have
to being in that role?
I mean, certainly you
can make recommendations.
You can say, let's
be the academic here.
Let's look at the data.
But I've also heard
this morning that you've
talked a lot about I believe
this, I believe that.
Those beliefs come
from somewhere.
How do you overcome that
in making those policy
recommendations when so
many people are listening?
CHRIS HUGHES: Well I don't
think you ever overcome it
in the sense that we all have
our subjective experiences.
And mine, the color of my
skin offers a privilege, which
we have to be honest about.
Certainly my economic
perspective offers a privilege.
I grew up in a
different setting,
but it very much does now.
I think the fact that I'm gay
gives me different goggles
to think about the world
and, to some extent,
about economic issues.
But at the end of
the day, I think
it's only through dialogue and
it's only through the people
that we support, particularly
through the Economic Security
Project-- we invest
millions of dollars
into leaders who
are out there who
teach me every day from
their perspectives.
And Mayor Tubbs is a
good example of one.
I was mentioning him earlier.
He's African American from
a city that is very diverse.
It has not been historically
led by African-American people.
And the people who are potential
beneficiaries of the program
come from all different
walks of life,
all different races, all
different kinds of backgrounds.
So I think that the
racial dimension
of the economic
injustice in particular
is so often overlooked.
I mean, 96% of the 1% are white.
And if you look at the people
who make $50,000 or less,
it is significantly more
people of color in that group
than if you look at the
population as a whole because
of the inherited structures
of racism and classism
in our country.
So I think that
without acknowledging
the importance of the
intersectionality of all
of these conversations,
none of this
is ever going to move forward.
Because fundamentally
there's a question,
I think, at the root of so
much of this work, which
is can you trust people
to be the masters
of their own destiny?
And that question
itself is so wrapped up
with the history of
racism in our country
that we have to have this
conversation ourselves.
So I'm up here today and in
general as a spokesperson
for nobody except myself.
And I hope we can cultivate a
group of leaders and conveners
of these kinds of
conversations who
come from every walk of life.
Because without that, we're
never going to be successful,
I think, in providing
financial security
to people who need it most.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: All
right, well let's thank Chris.
I want to say, he
has a lot of things
that he could do with
his time and his money,
and I really respect
that he has decided
to try to make America just
a little bit more equal.
So let's think Chris Hughes.
CHRIS HUGHES: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]